four words bro four words do you
remember the four words you said uh
chase excellence not women right so and
then the women will come so
um
you know we were just at the
cme the conference for masculine
excellence right so uh women want a
catch right like
i always
my mom is they want the whole package
they want the whole package they want an
excellent man they want to catch right
so you should be focusing on personal
growth getting better and things will
come so uh rolo speak what it what does
it take to be a
high value man an excellent man these
days i mean this is your wheelhouse and
the guys i look i assume everyone here
is watching because they want to get
faster smarter better wealthier
sexier if they're going to compete in
the marketplace of business and the
sexual markets right so speak to that i
think we use the term chase a little bit
too too much these days um when we talk
about chase it makes me think of like
little boys running after girls on the
playground when they're like in third
grade or something like that don't chase
girls excellent yeah
so so what is excellence to you i think
is the first thing that guys need to
understand like what what what does that
consist of does that mean you're making
a lot of money does that mean you're
going to be the
you know ceo of a company what what does
that look like to you because excellence
in a lot i mean maybe you're maybe
you're the quarterback of the football
team that's excellence you know
um so it i think that's the the first
thing you need to define is what what is
excellence to you what is uh you know
what are you passionate about what do
you make money doing that's fine you
know what do they say you know like if
you have a talent or something it's it's
one thing to have a talent it's another
thing to be able to develop that and to
actually use that talent and to i mean
there's plenty of the world's f you know
there's graveyards full of talented men
who had all kinds of you know god-given
gifts that never did anything with it
and so there's that aspect i think
that's a literal quote yeah something
like that but i'm paraphrasing but i
mean it's like you can you can be a
genius and if you don't know how to put
that genius to work or maybe it's being
exploited maybe you that's your
definition of how am i going to
be quote-unquote be excellent to each
other um but
yeah yeah i know you're really strong
hey not not quite so much um but uh i
think that that's that's number one and
then the other thing of course is i i
thought you were gonna say money muscles
and game and then the whole packages
frame
that's essentially
in the men's
self-improvement
uh sphere for lack of a better term uh
that's if
those are the three dynamics that most
guys either are really good in in one of
those or they're deficient in another
and so maybe
grossing out
well what happens is if somebody had is
really good with like okay i'm not a
very good looking guy so uh i'm going to
gross out in making a whole lot of money
bill gates bill gates good example right
uh zuckerberg i'll never get laid but
i'm i want to make a lot of money
because i think that you know i lead
with my wallet and and uh it's sex as a
transaction but i'm okay with that
because i'm bill gates look at me right
um
so there's what happens is when guys are
deficient in one or two of those areas
they tend to gross out in another area
so like really super rich men tend to
have like some of the worst game you'll
ever know like bezos for example elon
musk also for example people i i called
elon musk a beta on this very show at
one point people were like oh my god how
could he possibly say that he's the
richest man in the world it's like he's
got to be alpha and like no he's he
grosses out in one of those areas which
is he makes a lot of money right um and
then there's the you know the guys who
are like the fitness guys well at least
i can be really hot and i can be really
good looking i go take off my shirt down
at south beach and women flock to me or
whatever okay but i i'm i'm dirt poor
and i'm you know couch surfing on my
buddies you know couch at home right or
perhaps they um they get they gross out
in just being like really super slick
and super charming right there's that's
the game aspect of things now of course
the the total package that when women
say i want a guy who's got money and
he's got to love his mom and he's got a
you know it's this laundry list of
prerequisites and you know he's got a
he's got to be funny he's got to be
educated he's got to be taller than me
he's got it's like just this list this
laundry list of things now does that
mean that if you don't have one of those
things you're just absolutely screwed no
but what it's going to mean is that
you're going to compensate in other ways
so when we see a guy who's driving this
big giant monster truck out there what's
the first thing women say or even guys
he's got to be compensating for
something exactly and so we think of the
we think of compensation in those terms
don't have a car you can't even i'm just
an uber which comes back by the way to
competence and dominance right so
uh there you think of think of money
muscles and game and frame and all that
good stuff in terms of dominance
hierarchies as well because there's guys
who can still pull it off like i answer
this question all the time people say
well rolo i live in a small village in
you know by the seaside in chile and i
have to be a a dominant you know the
real g and i want to move to miami and
everything well those are good
aspirations but the thing is is like by
environment and by wherever it is that
you happen to be perhaps
in terms of like the context that you
are in maybe you are the the top g the
top alpha guy of your village in chile
or argentina or wherever it is that you
happen to be so by by by contextualizing
it you have to also think in terms of
like well socioeconomically where am i
ethnicity uh civilization wise
which country do i live in and i think
one of the things that we sort of get
lost in with respect to the red pill and
the stuff that i do is that we tend to
think of success as being the guy who
lives on a super yacht and he's draped
over a lamborghini and it's like that's
the that's the the apex of of being like
the the highest order guy right he
chased excellence right so here's his
excellence he's got a mclaren right well
if the red pill isn't for the guy who's
driving a tractor in oklahoma somewhere
in the midwest or whatever if it's not
for him it can't be for anybody and so
what i've been trying to do is really
sort of break things down so it doesn't
matter where you are
what you know sort of socioeconomic
class you happen to be in like you could
be salt of the earth kind of you know
heartland of america guy and you can
still benefit from from what it is that
i talk about what george talks about
heck whatever we every thursday out here
and if it's not accessible if it can't
be for the everyman then it's like what
are we really doing so when we talk
about chasing excellence that's why i
always say you know you gotta what is
excellence to you because excellence to
me sitting here in miami with with you
guys uh men of your caliber right now
is not going to be something that the
average guy you know watching this show
is going to have any frame of reference
for so when we talk about excellence
it's got to be something within the
context of something that you can
actually achieve that you're always
about and then the other part of that is
is people always say well chase
excellence don't chase women well the
problem is is that if you chase
excellence and that's all to the
exception of everything else that's why
i was mentioning you know grossing out
in one side if you chase excellence to
the exception of everything else and
everyone seems to think it's just making
a lot of money or focusing on your
passions or whatever like that and it's
what is it uh uh ignore women acquire
currency i've seen that meme before
don't send it to me thank you very much
um but the idea is is that if you have
all this stuff if you have this money
and everything then the women will come
and they'll they'll all want to flock
around you i'm like yeah the ones who
who are like lauren sanchez who wants to
get with jeff bezos
once the coast is clear mackenzie bezos
has their 33 billion dollars in divorce
because all you were doing was chasing
excellence you have no frame of
reference and no idea that you're
getting rolled by a predatory one let me
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]